Somebody asked me the other
day if I believed in miracles
and I hate being asked
questions like that,
you know,
and you know it's also
people ask me to do,
I believe in God and I don't know
what they mean when they say that.
So I don't know what to answer because
I don't think we're taught necessarily
going to talk about the same thing.
But in any case,
I said yes and I have a
variety of reasons for that,
but one of them is that,
you know,
the consensus among physicists is that
we can track the origin of the cosmos to
something like 100 million of a
millionth of a second after the big bang.
It's like it's so close
to the big bang that
the differences literally infinitesimal,
but the consensus is that before that,
whatever that is,
the laws of physics themselves breakdown,
well,
what,
what do you call an event that
exists outside the laws of physics?
That by definition that's a miracle.
Now,
that doesn't necessarily mean that there's
a transcendent daddy that caused the
event.
That's a separate issue.
But it does imply a barrier of some
sort beyond which we can't go where some
other set of rules apply.
And so I find that interesting as well.